big news today we know it's
on capitol hill there's a lot going on
today we will talk about i'll give you
the uh
the the lead into this and then we'll
kind of give uh some stories with this
so robin hood's ceo his name is vlad
tenev
he's reportedly staying at a hotel right
now instead of going home after
receiving
death threats that's pretty serious um
so robin hood ceo of vladtenap is
staying at a hotel because of the
backlash following
the gamestop trading rally in late
january was a couple weeks ago
robin hood restricted trading of
gamestop shares on january 28th
following a 2
000 surge in the share price driven by
retail investors robin hood users
including members of wall street's wall
street bets forum on reddit
uh who cheered gamestop's rally accused
the firm
of unfairly manipulating free market
trading some of the backlash was violent
tenev received death threats and has
avoided going home in the past
few days the police in menlo park
california which is basically just
outside silicon valley
they were told last week that a handful
of protesters had thrown
dog feces which is dog on at robin
hood's
headquarters and saw through a statue on
the property so people are running up
on robin hood's headquarters taneb is
said to testify in a congressional
hearing on thursday which is
today it could be happening any second
about the firm's decision
decision to restrict trading and let me
give you a little more insight here you
know i printed out this article right
here
so here are some of the players that are
going to be testifying uh
on capitol hill today so the leaders of
robin hood vlad
melvin capital which is a hedge fund
read it um
because we just talked about reddit uh
you know they received three billion
dollars of new funding
citadel they were all testify as well as
uh this is sort of like a reddit trading
star roaring kitty
all about last month's game uh gamestop
trading turmoil
um here's a couple quotes and then i'm
going to get it over to you guys so we
think congressional hearing will focus
on understanding exactly what
occurred during the week of service
disruptions making sure that all
activity was appropriate and also
determining how to avoid a similar event
in the future
the prevailing narrative was that a band
of reddit inspired
small traders rose up against wall
street
by buying gamestop forcing a short
squeeze by professional hedge fund
managers
who were forced to cover their negative
bets or risk
catastrophic losses losses
robin hood which is a millennial
favorite stock trading uh
they made the unpopular decision to
restrict trading of certain securities
obviously gamestop being one and then um
tenet is what he had to say i want to be
clear
any allegation that robin hood acted to
help hedge funds or any other special
interest to the detriment of
our customers is absolutely false
and marketing distorting rhetoric that's
the word from vlad tentative
um a lot of drama going on this is going
on on
on capitol hill today tom i know you've
got some strong feelings on this well
we'll we'll see the heat's going to be
on him
um i don't believe that quote what he
just said i think the hedge funds were
protected clearly
there is real anger i mean there are
some really really ticked off people
david portnoy is
you know the founder of barstool i mean
he wants him out um
calling for his head yeah you know he's
one of the he he founded this thing he's
a co-founder
of robin hood and and you know yeah and
it was you know it's a popular i mean a
highly thought of app
until a few weeks ago and now it's gone
all gone in the toilet
i think his days are numbered i think
they've got to get him out i mean oh you
think he's done
well how does he stay that's what i say
because as a ceo you want to you know
exude some strength and some confidence
and some
you know you know project that you know
what you're doing and that you can
control a crisis
and that just hasn't happened i don't
think it's a great look when you say
you're hiding out in hotels and you're
the ceo now
i've never had death threats so i don't
know what i would do so i'm not going to
try to act like i'm in his shoes
but you know though death threats get
thrown out there a lot um there's a
difference between a death threat where
you're in true danger and someone's
going to come to your house and kill you
or someone posting something really
stupid on social media does that count
as a death threat
i mean it does it does i know in the in
the definition but is it
how legit is it i i don't know you're
saying there's different levels well
kind of
um i i would bro we should rip his head
off
it's better to be safe than sorry true
but then how about saying something like
this
i've got around the clock security
around me because i'm still working and
i'm trying to fix this mess
for the people that feel like they you
know that that they weren't handled
fairly and this is a quote from from our
friend vlad and then we'll
flip it over to kai he says as soon as
the emails went out talking about what
happened with uh
robin hood the conspiracy theory started
coming so my phone
was blowing up how could you do this how
could you be on the side of the hedge
funds which he says he's not
taneb who is 33 years old respect to at
least you know
young dudes making things happen is
reportedly being coached
for the hearing by robin hood's chief
legal officer dan gallagher a former sec
commissioner
who also coached none other than mark
zuckerberg on his congressional hearing
right
right you need to be coached you can't
go in front of these guys without being
prepared
what's the quote guy
you know i think it'll be a fun thing to
watch today i think it'll be really
interesting i mean
you go into these saying is it going to
be a dog and pony show because a lot of
times
the senators like to huff and puff and
nothing gets done right they pull you in
front of congress
they have a congressional hearing they
act all tough but then nothing really
gets done this might be a little
different today
it'll be interesting to see how he
handles the bright lights of this type
of scrutiny
and you know i'll say this about the guy
i know nothing really about him okay i
just kind of evaluate by
you know what he's doing since this
crisis started and i don't think it's
been stellar
number one but he probably got into this
business with good intentions if you
name your company robin hood
right so you know it's not like he's
when you set something up like that it's
almost like you're not
in favor from the right to the poor but
the hedge funds know what they're doing
on all these transactions
they're gonna and they're gonna
manipulate this thing to their advantage
so
it'll be interesting he's been under the
radar and under the you know the public
profile for so long but today it's the
opposite of that and
he could get exposed or he could come
across as someone that can say the
dude's in a hard place and we talked
about this a couple weeks ago and i used
the quote uh from what's the song
from reservoir dogs well a little green
bag and he's like clowns to the left of
me joker's to the right here i am stuck
in the middle with you he's getting his
funding
from big uh wall street firms hedge
funds you know investment firms like
that
but his customers are the millennial
retail traders like the guys on reddit's
uh who are so i mean you're you're
really in a hard place right there
so he has to obviously appeal to where
he's getting his money
clearly because he can't like just say
oh f you guys because then maybe the
business gets
screwed but he obviously can't screw
over his actual customer base
he's in a tough spot but uh kai what are
your thoughts on this
no i think uh if you think of it and
again this is reportedly staying at a
hotel so it's not confirmed that he's
staying at the
marriott resort whatever whatever uh so
for all we know this could be
fake news like we know there's more than
you don't think he's
no we who knows i think he's like faking
that he's staying at a hotel
reportedly withdraw sympathy who knows
this might be something the old reporter
howard
this might seem like he's a coward uh
however
i'd think he's staying at a hotel bro i
mean who i mean if
he probably has a security still i i i
don't buy the hotel thing
you don't think okay i stay at a lot of
hotels i don't want vlad next to me
and the people trying to kill him okay
out right now yeah i think it's more
dangerous if you go to a hotel you're
putting everybody else in jeopardy yeah
stay away from my hotels um however i do
i do think that uh tom has a point uh
that um
the people that are the traders like the
day traders and a lot of these people
that that joined the wall street bets i
see them as the people that are gamers
they're the t people that are kind of
like trolls where they're they're
keyboard warriors like people call them
where they s they throw a lot of
board warriors warriors yeah exactly
where they throw a lot of questions
what's the famous drake quote he goes
trigger fingers turned to twitter
fingers yeah something like that no
it's that perfect it's that used to you
know back in the day you'd roll up on
somebody whatever
yeah i don't like you i'm the toughest
guy on youtube
i'll show you what's going on buddy oh
he's a soy boy yeah so
we had to go there so uh so i think a
lot of these people that are
just accusations now however you got to
take them serious to an extent of
of making sure you're protected and
you're taking proper precautions
um but i do also think that this this is
this will fade
uh it's a storm and it's obviously
weathering up this too shall pass it's
two shots well here you brought up the
you know the gamification of this um
here's some of the uh here's a quote by
representative james comer from kentucky
he's a republican he told cnbc he's been
proud to see a company like robin hood
emerge leveling the play field for
retail investors so he's sort of on the
side of robinhood he says
however cromer here's a quote so robin
hood may be a glorification
of the gamification of investments if
you want an exciting video interface
you should go to gamestop and buy video
game don't go to robin hood
to buy gamestop is that essentially what
you're saying here is that it's just
they're if you want to play video games
go play video games kai is a great video
gamer
but if you want to trade trading um no
i'd say investing is supposed to be
boring
is essentially what he's trying to say
i'm not i don't necessarily that's not
what i'm pointing to
what i'm pointing at is the people that
are doing this and that are part of the
wall street bets and the part of all
this movement of let's short gamestop or
let's increase game stop
i think these are the type of people
that would also be
more in that in the prone to play be
playing video games
or talking trash over the internet or
just plus they're in forums
where you can get to yeah exactly so i
want to know from
our audience are you guys on the side of
robin hood or are you
are you guys doing anything with
robinhood are you investing
is um you know where where are you at
with this are you pro-vat
vlad i just i love the comment section
over here kai would you mind would you
manage that
what's so funny hey
you know am i getting crushed over here
you know you know it's go you got some
supporters
you have some some some hate uh you know
it's it's
trigger fingers turn to twitter fingers
buddy this is what this is what it is
what we're doing is
a bunch of keyboard warriors in this
chat keyboard warriors and we love it if
they're not talking about you you're not
doing something right
the the first time i heard about this
yeah you know because this did take
this was so big a few weeks ago it was
just crazy i re there's a convenience
store where i live and
i would go in there and the guy that
works there would go i don't know why he
decided to tell me this but
hey man hey i i bought some amc stock
and i'm going god you know that's really
that's interesting and and that's all i
thought it was just randomly told
and i'm going man that's really cool
that you did that i mean that you found
the time i i find it a little bit odd
this is before i knew anything about
what was going on i found it a little
bit odd you know with movie theaters
being down but maybe he's thinking that
they're going to come back or he's got
some information
and then the next day i'd go in there
and he told me about more stock and this
and that
and then i talked to him i saw him on
sunday i said hey man i was trying to
reach you i wanted to find out how how
things went for you what did you do he
goes
he bought it at six it was as low as six
right amc
i think he got he said he made thirty
thousand
thirty thousand bucks doing this thing
wow he's kept it in there
he hasn't been able to get it out yet or
he's chosen not to maybe he's gonna like
keep it in there and move on
yeah well i think he may have had some
game stop too but mario would you pull
up
game stop stock let's see what this has
to say
because gamestop lost 90 like my point
is value
my point is he's not the guy you would
expect to be some guy that would be
making a small fortune you know
investigating this guy that works at the
gas station
well at a convenience store and here he
had that opportunity through robin hood
it's the type of person it caters to but
he got his information from reddit
i mean they were getting their marching
orders and they just said what i mean
clearly yeah i got asked about it but
that's how they all did it you know
that's where the forum was it's
collective it's
it's collective and and i think that
that is what tom saying that it's not
these typical people that
would and then obviously a situation
like this there's a
there isn't a realistic return that this
happens all the time like this is a
the frustrating thing is if you had if
you know you made money and they want to
like get it out
right i mean yeah and that that's where
the real anger is they would stop the
truth they would only let you
sell they wouldn't let you buy is that
what was that was going on yeah
there was a period on robin hood where
they shut down buying and they would
only let you sell
now robin hood claims that that's
because they they needed enough cash on
reserve
because from my understanding how it
works is that they there's a there's a
time when robin hood when you buy the
the app on robin hood
is obviously just kind of the interface
and then on the back end they
then buy it from somebody else that that
kind of does it on the back end
so they were saying that they didn't
have enough money to support
the trades that were being bought and so
or bought
and that's why they had to do another
round of funding to get in more money so
they'd be able to pull
have the pool to cover their costs the
funny the funny part of the story is
watching
those hedge fund managers who everybody
thought was so smart get
killed yeah and i think and obviously
and obviously i see that a lot of the
people were
saying main street versus wall street
and that main street won
and stuff like that and i agree and for
hedge funds now obviously they're trying
to claim that this was
all bad and they're going after the main
street people but
in a sense they lost like they they just
need to take the l and stop crying the
biggest winners
yeah were the hedge funds that bailed
out the other hedge funds steve cohen
the new owner of the mets yep
he came to the rescue of a couple of
them and you could you imagine the terms
on those
that's like you think you're the big
owner probably oh yeah yeah to bail him
out in a matter of days and pump a
couple billion
into their accounts so they don't get
destroyed or good point let's talk about
this game stop
stop can you go up max yeah go max mario
yeah i mean look look at that surgery
even even there if you look at it it's
now at 45.
go uh before the peak see where it was
at before the peak just
six months mario yeah you're looking at
six months
that's good you're still looking at what
it went from 45
to and before that it was at what five
ten
yeah so that's a forex return since the
beginning of january
i'd like to see how many senators made
money on this i bet they did i bet
there's a few
well speaking of senators let's talk
about what you know she's not in the
news a lot these days but she's going to
go get take her mantle today
senator elizabeth warren of
massachusetts a long-standing critic of
wall street is calling for a
ban on a forced arbitration which
essentially
prevents consumers from going to court
if they are wronged by a company or
product because
they agreed to the terms of service
interesting she's not sort of defending
the retail
traders out there here's what she said
robin hood promised to democratize
trading
but hid information about its
prerogative to change the rules by
cutting off trades without notice
and about cons customers inability to
access the courts
if they believe they've been cheated
behind dozens of pages of legalese
warren said in a statement what is not
clear from robin hood's response to my
questions
is the full extent of robin hood's ties
here it is kai
to giant hedge funds and market makers
i'm going to keep pushing regulators
to use the full range of their
regulatory tools to ensure the fair
operation of our market
particularly for small investors so she
is on the side of the small investors
because that
initial sentence threw me off were yeah
with this guy
i was confused what you were reading
yeah i say next story yeah
we're moving on to the next story she's
anti-capitalism we should ignore
everything she said so we're not on the
fa we're not on the side
so here's what we're doing there you go
nice try elizabeth warren
you're out so if you enjoyed this little
short segment from the podcast that we
did here's another short segment to
watch or if you want to see the entire
podcast
click over here take care everybody
[Music]
bye-bye